Now let's start defining some
basic operations on vectors.
The first operation we will describe for
vectors is addition.
One way to visualize the sum of two
vectors is to lay them end to end.
The arrow formed starting at
the tail of the first arrow and
ending at the head of the second
arrow gives the overall total amount
of change by the two vectors.
This new arrow is the sum
of the first two vectors.
In addition to this geometric
interpretation of vector addition
we have a numeric interpretation.
Given the first two vectors as a list of
coordinates, we can add the two vectors
by adding the corresponding
coordinates of each vector.
Since this first vector is [1 2] and
the second vector is [3 1].
There are some vector is [4 3].
Notice that if we lay out
the vectors in a parallelogram shape
the sum vector connects the points or
both chains of vector start
in this case the origin and
where the chains both end.
We can subtract vectors in
addition to adding them.
Here is the geometric interpretation
of vector subtraction.
Consider the vectors the v and
w both emanating from the same point
what vector would we need to add
to w in order for the sum to be v?
We represent this geometrically by
drawing an arrow from the head of w
to the head of v.
This vector is what we call v- w,
since w + the vector v- w equals v.
Numerically we can compute
the difference between two vectors by
subtracting their
corresponding coordinates.
So taking this vector to be [1 3] and
this vector to be [5 1],
their difference is [-4 2].
This is reflected in our drawing
since the difference vector
represents a change of four units
to the left and two units up.
This time, if we look at our
parallelogram formed by x and y.
Notice that x- y connects the heads of
the two initial vectors in our chains.
If we reverse the direction of
this arrow, we'll obtain y- x.
Another important operation on
vectors is scalar multiplication.
In this case a vector is multiplied
by a number which we call a scalar.
The term scalar is suggestive
of the word scale.
Which is fitting because the geometric
interpretation of scalar multiplication
is to scale the size of a vector.
Multiplying a vector by
2 doubles its length.
Multiplying a vector by 1
keeps it the same length.
Multiplying a vector by 1/2
cuts its length in half.
We can also multiply a vector
by a negative number.
This reverses the direction
the arrow points
in addition to possibly growing or
shrinking the vector.
Numerically scalar multiplication
is computed by multiplying
each coordinate of
the vector by the scalar.
So, 2 times the vector
[1 2] equals[ 2 4] and
-1/2 times the vector [3 2 1]
equals the vector [-3/2 -1 -1/2].